[Musica]
mi chiamo michele di stefano e da quasi
30 anni mi occupo di formazione
consulenza rivolta ai professionisti
della creatività e della cui
no quello che ci ha appena stato non è
stato un problema tecnico che cosa avete
provato come vi siete sentiti
se pensate che questa sensazione di
disagio non vi riguardi vi state
sbagliando perché forse non ci avete mai
pensato ma siamo tutti temporaneamente
abili
essendo una persona curiosa e
appassionata di tecnologia spesso circo
dei contenuti da affiancare a quelli che
utilizzo per fare formazione perché
reputo che fare formazione rendendola
più coinvolgente e accattivante sia
anche più efficace durante questa
ricerca
mi sono imbattuta nel video di
un'azienda famosa che ha realizzato per
le parole in piedi di nuoto una cuffia
dotata di un dispositivo bluetooth che
permette al nuotatore non vedente di
fare la virata nel momento esatto il suo
allenatore da bordo piscina manda un
segnale tramite un'app che fa vibrare la
cuffia e il nuotatore non vedente riesce
a fare la virata nel momento corretto
questo va eliminare quella che si
chiamava la bottarella cioè l'allenatore
da bordo piscina con un lungo bastone
toccava il nuotatore non vedente per
permettergli di fare la virata nel
momento esatto
come potete capire la tecnologia ha
nettamente migliorato la vita delle
persone disabili
pensate per esempio la possibilità di
farsi recapitare la spesa a casa con l'e
commerce
oppure la possibilità di partecipare
all'università con leader ning la
possibilità di gestire la domotica con i
comandi vocali ma anche la bionica con
le sue protesi e i suoi esoscheletri che
va a ridurre nettamente il gap fra le
persone disabili e quelle abili ma che
cos'è l'accessibilità l'accessibilità e
il design di prodotti ambienti o servizi
sviluppati per le persone con disabilità
e chi sono le persone con disabilità
leggo testualmente dalla convenzione onu
sui diritti delle persone con disabilità
del 2006 ratificata in italia nel 2009
le persone con disabilità include
quanti hanno minorazioni fisiche mentali
intellettuali o sensoriali a lungo
termine che in interazione con varie
barriere possono impedire la loro piena
ed effettiva partecipazione nella
società su una base di uguaglianza con
gli altri e tutte queste persone
utilizzano la tecnologia ci sono vari
tipi di disabilità disabilità visive e
uditive motorie cognitive come la
dislessia la discalculia l'autismo e ci
sono vari tipi di tecnologie assistive
come per esempio gli screen reader gli
ingranditori le grandi tastiere tattili
i mouse per la testa
i comandi vocali ma anche i sottotitoli
chi sicuramente ognuno di noi avrà usato
almeno una volta per vedere un video e
non essere disturbato dall'audio oppure
se pensiamo alle barriere
architettoniche la conca dei marciapiedi
che ci permette di scendere con un
passeggino con un carrello della spesa
con uno skateboard con una bicicletta ma
che sono essenziali per le persone su
una carrozzina
come potete immaginare non esiste
un'anagrafe della disabilità perché
essendo un dato sensibile come tale va
protetto e va a impattare in modo
profondo sulla vita lavorativa sulla
vita dell'apprendimento e sulla vita
sociale
ciò nonostante per la prima volta nel
l'istat ha prodotto un rapporto dal
quale emerge che in italia ci sono 3
milioni e 100mila persone disabili e
rappresentano il 52 per cento della
popolazione e pensate più del 50 per
cento hanno più di 75 anni e più del 60
per cento sono donne
se pensate che questo argomento ancora
non interesse vi state sbagliando perché
domani potremmo avere un incidente
potremmo perdere la vista l'udito
rimanere temporaneamente o
definitivamente su una carrozzina ma la
cosa che non possiamo evitare in nessun
modo è quella di invecchiare e in questo
momento non possiamo sapere in che modo
pertanto siamo tutti temporaneamente
abili latte
oggi a viene considerata una risorsa
democratica e come tale dovrebbe essere
accessibile a chiunque senza alcuna
differenza
purtroppo non è così se pensate che la
web haim ha analizzato nel 2019 2020
2021 un milione di siti web è fra i
migliori siti web ed è emerso da questo
rapporto che il 97,4 per cento di questi
siti non è accessibile se pensiamo quei
contenuti testuali come per esempio pdf
tranne casi virtuosi
la situazione forse anche peggiore
ma perché non c'è interesse verso questo
argomento
quali potrebbero essere le motivazioni
pensiamo per esempio a un sito web un
sito web magari accessibile si può
pensare che sia non altrettanto
accattivante come uno che non lo è
in realtà vi mostro una slide dove
potete vedere due o page di siti web
accessibili e non noterete alcuna
differenza dal punto di vista della
grafica o della creatività io dal 2011
mi occupo anche di editoria digitale e
sto cercando di divulgare la conoscenza
del formato epub il formato epub è uno
standard html compresso zippato e quindi
un formato standard ed è un formato
particolarmente accessibile perché è in
grado di essere eletto facilmente dagli
screen reader informati pub di fatto si
adatta alla dimensione dello schermo
permette di ingrandire e ridurre la
dimensione dei caratteri ed è quindi un
formato particolarmente accessibile per
tutti ci permette di navigare anche
tramite i link che ci sono nel sommario
di spostarsi dalle note al testo e
viceversa
e questo lo rende un formato adatto per
tutti anche alle persone abili
se io arrivo casa la sera voglio leggere
un libro dopo tante ore davanti al
computer
posso ingrandire il testo ed evitare di
stancare la vista oppure posso
utilizzare il comando addirittura vocale
a voce alta quindi il formato epub è di
fatto un formato di alta qualità per
tutti
secondo voi il popolo italiano è un
popolo di lettori ci sono 130
7 mila persone non vedenti in italia e
circa un milione e mezzo di persone
ipovedenti e pensate le persone non
vedenti leggono 9,2 libri all'anno
contro due persone su dieci vedenti che
ne leggono altrettanti quindi per
assurdo le persone non vedenti sono
degli appassionati lettori
quando pensiamo quindi i contenuti
accessibili dobbiamo ricordarci che non
parliamo solo di barriere
architettoniche ma anche di contenuti
testuali abbiamo sentito spesso dire il
contenuto e re l'importanza della user
experience dell'interfaccia utente
dell'esperienza di viaggio di lettura di
acquisto
ma tutto questo deve essere per tutti
per fortuna ci sono due buone notizie la
prima è che il contesto normativo sta
cambiando e già da settembre 2020 è
entrata in vigore la direttiva europea
sull'accessibilità che prevede che le
organizzazioni private ei loro fornitori
realizzino di contenuti accessibili per
quanto riguarda il web e le app e questa
situazione andrà migliorando nel 2025
quando entrerà in vigore l'atto europeo
sull'accessibilità che stende questa
richiesta anche alle organizzazioni
private e tutto quello che riguarda
l'hardware il software quindi i servizi
di e commerce i servizi bancari i
trasporti di reader gli smartphone i
tablet
la seconda buona notizia è che ci sono
già sul mercato dei professionisti
preparati per affiancare le aziende a
trasformare i loro contenuti in
contenuti accessibili
io ne faccio parte e sono anche in grado
di formare le aziende affinché possano
realizzare in autonomia dei contenuti
accessibili ma perché ci preoccupiamo di
questo argomento
o meglio perché ci dobbiamo preoccupare
di questo argomento perché siamo
responsabili dei contenuti che
realizziamo perché abbiamo un dovere
etico nei confronti delle persone con
disabilità
abbiamo l'interesse a fare in modo che i
nostri contenuti raggiungano il maggior
numero di utenti possibili e desideriamo
che la tecnologia sia veramente una
risorsa democratica è a disposizione di
tutti
senza alcuna distinzione ma se non
vogliamo farlo per tutte queste
motivazioni
possiamo farlo per noi per il fatto che
tutti invecchiamo non sappiamo in che
modo e dobbiamo ricordarci che siamo
tutti temporaneamente abili e visto il
lavoro che c'è ancora da fare
forse è meglio cominciare subito grazie